>> President Trump: THIS IS
OUR NEW AMERICAN MOMENT.
THERE IS NEVER BEEN A BETTER
TIME TO START LIVING THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
SO TO EVERY CITIZEN WATCHING AT
HOME TONIGHT, NO MATTER WHERE
YOU SPEND OR WHERE YOU’VE COME
FROM, THIS IS YOUR TIME.
IF YOU WORK HARD, IF YOU BELIEVE
IN YOURSELF KIND IF YOU IN
AMERICA, THEN YOU CAN DREAM
YOU CAN BE ANYTHING.
TOGETHER WE CAN ACHIEVE
ABSOLUTELY ANYTHING.
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT EARLIER TONIGHT.
HERE WITH REACTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT MOMENT IS HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN.
LET’S TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THE IMMIGRATION PROPOSALS.
GIVE US SOME DETAIL.
>> SURE, SO WHAT I THINK WHAT
THE PRESIDENT LAID OUT IS THAT
CLEAR VISION.
PART OF THE BORDERS IS NOT JUST
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT IS THE TECHNOLOGY, PERSONNEL,
AND CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE SO WE
CAN REMOVE THOSE WHO COME HERE
ILLEGALLY.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS CLEAR.
HE ASKED FOR BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IT WAS REALLY A UNIFYING MOMENT
I THINK ON SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
>> Sean: SECRETARY, I’VE BEEN
DOWN TO THE BORDER A DOZEN
TIMES.
I’VE BEEN FROM THE RIO GRANDE TO
SAN DIEGO.
I’VE SEEN DRUG WAREHOUSES.
I’VE SEEN GANG MEMBERS.
I’VE BEEN IN HELICOPTERS, BOATS,
ALL-TERRAIN VEHICLES.
YOU CAN LAUGH AT ME ON
HORSEBACK.
I’VE SEEN ALL OF THIS AND WE
ALWAYS END UP GETTING THE
CONSIDERATION, THE AMNESTY GOING
BACK TO ’86.
WE NEVER, EVER GET THE WALL
FUNDED AND BUILT.
IS THIS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT?
WILL THE PRESIDENT INSISTS ON
THE MONEY THAT HE CONTROLS TO
BUILD THE BORDER BEFORE ANY
DEAL?
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE THE WALL.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THE WALL.
WALLS WORK.
WE’VE SEEN IT IN SAN DIEGO.
AND THE FUNDING.
HE’S BEEN CLEAR.
IN THE PROPOSAL, HE OFFERED LAST
WEEK, $25 BILLION FUND WHICH
WILL INCLUDE NOT ONLY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT TECHNOLOGY
FOR THE SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN
BORDER AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
PERSONNEL COSTS AND THINGS WE
NEED.
I THINK HE’S MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THIS IS A PRIORITY.
OUR BORDER, AS YOU KNOW, SEAN,
IS MORE SECURE THAN IT’S BEEN IN
THE PAST.
HOWEVER THE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE.
WE HAD A 300% INCREASE IN
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS.
WE ALSO HAD A 600% INCREASE IN
FAMILY UNITS.
WHEN WE TALK -- THE PRESIDENT
TALKED ABOUT GANGS TONIGHT.
IT’S TIME TO DO IT.
HE’S VERY COMMITTED.
I AM COMMITTED.
I WILL WORK WITH ANYONE AND
EVERYONE WHO WILL TALK TO ME
ABOUT THIS.
>> Sean: MADAM SECRETARY, I
HAVE SEEN IT FIRSTHAND.
IN TERMS OF NATIONAL SECURITY,
IT’S IF NOT THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY WE HAVE.
I SUSPECT WHEN CHUCK SCHUMER
PULLED HIS OFFER OFF THE TABLE
AND THEN LISTENING TO OTHER
DEMOCRATS, IT SOUNDS TO ME
POLITICALLY THEY DON’T WANT A
DEAL.
THEY DON’T WANT DACA.
THEY WANT TO RUN ON DACA IN
2018.
FOR ALL THEIR SANCTIMONY, I
SUSPECT POLITICALLY THEY ARE
VERY DIFFERENT MOTIVES.
AND THEN YOU HAVE LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS LIKE LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND SENATOR SNOWFLAKE -- I AM
SORRY.
JEFF FLAKE.
I CALL HIM SNOWFLAKE.
OUT IN ARIZONA, SEEMS LIKE THEY
WANT AMNESTY.
>> WELL, SEAN, IT’S
DISAPPOINTING BECAUSE
SENATOR SCHUMER VOTED FOR THE
WALL.
MANY OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES HAVE VOTED FOR THE
WALL.
THIS IS POLITICS.
I THINK WHAT YOU HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT TONIGHT IS ENOUGH OF
THAT.
IT WAS A UNIFYING MESSAGE.
IT WAS A CALL ACROSS THE AISLE.
IT WAS A CALL ACROSS BOTH HOUSES
OF CONGRESS.
IT WAS A CALL TO ACTION.
IT’S TIME TO DO IT.
WE NEED TO INCREASE THE SECURITY
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT’S TIME TO REFORM AND
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM THAT’S ON
AUTOPILOT AND IS NOT IN ANY WAY
HELP IMPROVE OUR ECONOMY.
>> Sean: DO YOU SUSPECT AS I
DO THAT THERE IS POLITICS BEING
PLAYED BY THE DEMOCRATS?
IN OTHER WORDS, I QUESTION THE
SINCERITY OF WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT THIS DEAL BECAUSE AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID, THIS IS A
COMPROMISE DEAL.
YOU GET WHAT YOU WANT AND WE
WILL GET WHAT WE RAN ON.
>> NO, I THINK IT IS A
COMPROMISE.
HE LISTENED TO MEMBERS FROM BOTH
PARTIES, AS DID I.
AND ALL I CAN TELL YOU WITH
RESPECT TO THAT IS WE ARE
COMMITTED.
WE ARE NEGOTIATING IN GOOD
FAITH.
I’VE BEEN ON THE HILL MANY TIMES
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS, TALKED
TO HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
I WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
I’VE BEEN TO THE BORDER MYSELF.
TALK TO STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS THERE AS WELL AS
LANDOWNERS AND AMERICANS WHO
LIVE THERE AND SEE THE THREATS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
WE ARE NEGOTIATING IN GOOD
FAITH.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
I HOPE THEY WILL AGREE TO DO THE